hello let's do some ghetto trivia here
let me see who anybody won't answer any
questions any ghetto questions who it
who wants to come on let's go come on
y'all come on get all trivia let's do it
here's the question you ready alright
anybody can answer it how many times do
you put your code in on the link car
before the link car shut down if you put
the wrong code in that's the real
question how many times can you put a
bad code here before I said that three
look he do it on a blood okay I got one
more question all right I'm going to
forget her homie again what's your name
man they don't make a difference in the
ghetto you don't have your regular name
um money and money all right
you coming in late from the club you see
a neighbor breaking into somebody else's
car you know it's not a car what do you
do
you are my Joe's damn finish you all
right give a round applause it ain't
because if say your neighbor and they
know you snitch they're gonna break it
yo [ __ ] mix so ghetto trivia smiling
your [ __ ] business you got two
for to look at you see that's what I'm
saying it's for everybody
[Music]
you
[Music]